Oh Yemen's Houthi rebels say they've
launched their biggest ever military
operation against Saudi Arabia eight
drones and three ballistic missiles have
been fired towards Saudi Arabia since
Monday the Houthis say they plan to
launch more Saudi coalition fighting in
Yemen says it intercepted a ballistic
missile headed towards Riyadh the
coalition spokesman says the attack was
launched from the Yemeni capital sana
towards civilian targets in the kingdom
let's bring in Matt moon uber Noir he's
a retired Jordanian Air Force general
good to have you with us so first of all
do we know is there any evidence to
establish how successful a strike this
was did the missiles and drones hit
their targets or not it's very difficult
to tell we need some more information
the wreckage the you know so it would be
difficult but reaching Riyadh with that
accuracy and the planning to head that
Ministry of Defense and some other
military airport that's big escalation I
could sing because the Houthi now is
winning on the ground and Joel's some
part of Yemen so yes it's make this
audience acute the unstable for any
investment in the future and so big
threat for the Saudi air defense system
which I feel it's a bit weak to
intercept such missiles they need the
Sadd system which will intercept beyond
the atmosphere tell us why you think the
Saudi air defense system is weak here
because of course the Saudi narrative is
that they intercepted and shot down
these missiles and drones motivated
defense system around the world even the
percentage of hitting this target as
like 20 percent or so so that's why the
ballistic missile normally reach and
normally when this missile entered
atmosphere the warhead and departed
separated from each other so it's very
hard to hit or to treat such an attack
and this LD need the fat system and
early warning and the area is so vast or
need more radars etc that's why they
asked the American talk them out last
two three months if you remember sorry
right so it's gonna be yeah it's gonna
be at unprecedented was the number of
missiles and drones and again there are
kind of two claims and counterclaims
about how many missiles and drones were
launched well I don't have enough info
but I think as the news we hit the news
that's like like four missile and some
eight drones and some cruise even so but
what's notable here is they attack a
military target not civilian ones but
they have the accuracy and they have the
range if you remember with some odd
three drones they hit Abu Dhabi
cake and crazy Aramco cetera so they
have this edge and they change the
balance of the tie of the war concerning
the Emirates and the Saudi but it's also
it's amazing but they are not treating
the Emirati the same you know launching
such thing I think the Emirati there
through the Iranian they ask not to be
hit or something like that so I'm not
sure about that that segues nicely into
my question about what does this strike
tell us about the Houthis technological
capabilities because as you said I mean
we're talking about the people you know
merge from mountains around Sun are now
apparently or allegedly according to
their claims they targeting ministries
in Riyadh on the other side of the
Arabian Peninsula yes I think we have
the edge I've said they change it of the
world they open eyes the drones they
have deep elastic and they have the also
the the cruise missile which is very
effective very hard to hit this target
this cruise missile so there are a big
spread to this out yes and they can hit
anywhere and South your Emirates even
they can't reach Israel I could say now
so that's what's happening in Yemen it's
a full of chaos there I think the best
way to solve the EM anything is to salut
D and the Marathi should withdrawn from
Yemen at all they have they paid
billions of dollars and see what's
happening now in South Yemen and I don't
think they will leave such way because
they need socotra who control socotra to
control the seven seas in the world's a
trendy need the port the all these
facilities or I don't think they will
leave Yemen very soon so they invested
invested in billions of dollars and they
need some return for that and that's
what they're looking for they failed to
contain the Iranian and they failed even
to defeat this rule see so and I don't
see this agreement we had agreement or
resolution two two one six UN is working
anymore so they need Saudi if they it's
it's a it's a terrible case same and
it's it's it's a cutter software I think
and the word should interfere now to
stop them but they will be nice I think
what they doing they are organizing code
nineteen covered nineteen to get the M
and with these all hangers I think most
people will agree it is a catastrophe
that's going on there thanks so much
Matt moon a beurre Noir